hey friends it's a delight to be
introducing you to lyman page one of my
oldest and greatest of all colleagues
and inspiration
a mentor a friend one of the pioneers
behind the
cosmology experiment called toco that
was the first to reveal the universe was
spatially flat
meaning that any triangle that you could
make as big as you want in the entirety
of the universe will still have its
interior angles add up to 180 degrees
just like a triangle on a flat piece of
paper
so he measured the curvature of the
universe founding it to be flat
and that's kind of funny because
nowadays many people claim the earth is
flat while the earth isn't flat but the
universe is flat and lyman will tell us
a little bit about that on today's
episode he'll also recount some stories
from the famous wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe which he co-led as one
of the chief scientists on that program
and if you go to wikipedia
the source of all knowledge and you type
in the word science which means
knowledge you will see a picture that
was produced by the wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe
which was co-developed along with lyman
page and his team members at princeton
and nasa goddard space flight center and
he's just such a mercurial wonderful
human being i love working with him he's
brilliant i always learn something new
from him and he's a gentleman and he's
still got that boyish charm even at age
64 as he is now stronger than ever
working harder than ever to uncover the
mysteries of the universe so today
you're going to learn some really
fascinating lessons and i hope that
you'll uh really
uh enjoy it and leave a comment as to
what's your favorite story from our
conversation lymon's a great rock on
tour and don't forget to leave a review
wherever you're watching this leave a
thumbs up
comment anything will help us in our
battle with the eternal cosmic algorithm
and we've grown so much in this year and
i'm so thankful to everyone out there
listening or watching dr brian keating
on youtube or into the impossible
podcast
love you all and looking forward to many
many great things coming in 2022 stay
tuned you won't want to miss it
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
open the pod bay hell
welcome everybody to a special edition
of the into the impossible podcast
i am your fearful host
brian keating and this time of pandemic
podcasting is a great thrill to welcome
a friend
a mentor whether he likes it or not
professor lyman page who is the uh james
s mcdonnell distinguished university
professor of physics
at princeton university in princeton new
jersey he's the author most recently of
the little book of cosmology which is
delightful in many many ways and we'll
get into all the ways that it's
influenced me
but i want to start lymon by taking you
back 22 years ago this month this will
come out in june i think 22 years ago
was june of 1999
and in that year you and your team and
your graduate students and postdocs
released a paper
and that paper uh had a very understated
title and the title uh had to do with a
measurement of the angular power
spectrum of the cosmic microwave
background between multiples of 100 and
400
what is that paper what was that paper
what does it mean to cosmology what did
it reveal about the universe that no one
ever knew before you and your
collaborators and teammates made that
measurement oh yeah well thanks for
remembering the paper yes it was uh
amber miller's
paper
and
that was sort of the core of her thesis
um
so this was a measurement actually the
paper combined a number of measurements
we've made over the years
and the last one was uh an ex from the
telco experiment that we uh did in chile
with with the crew there with with uh
mark devlin at penn
and
what we were able to do
is is map out the position and amplitude
of the first peak
in the microwave background and
we were able to show that it
we're pretty sure it was from the cosmic
microwave background because it had the
right spectrum
uh we had a lot of redundancy built into
the
you know to the measurement
um
it matched really well with our earlier
measurements where we saw the rise the
peak and sort of went over in this
experiment because we'd gone to higher
frequencies
and smaller
beams we could get over the peak
and
what the position of the peak told us is
that the geometry of the universe is
flat
given reasonable assumptions about the
hubble constant
so we were yeah i was a little
understated but we what we wanted to uh
you know i think these days of course we
would have
put out such a paper with parameter
estimates but we wanted to just stick
really closely to the data
and and get it out there and yes as you
know it's very competitive time there
are a lot of other other groups that
uh the
boomerang guys were
gearing up but we had this great
measurement and yeah no we're quite
proud of it
and when you look at that uh i remember
that being sort of the holy grail
of cosmology at that time at least in
experimental capacity
that everybody wanted to measure it
everybody wanted to make this
measurement of the geometry of the
universe and why not because you know
the last person who made such
substantial contributions to measuring
geometry was you know aristophanes and
you know irish markets and uh
and you guys were doing similar things
um and you know kind of made me wonder
what what about uh cosmology today
uh is is really tantamount to that that
is sort of expected on one hand you know
that we we thought the universe was
likely to be consistent with the flat
universe from arguments going back to
dickie and others
but also that the universe you know had
some surprises up its sleeve as we would
find out around that time as well dark
energy etc is there anything analogous
in in in in our field of experimental
cosmology that's sort of a known unknown
or maybe an unknown known uh that will
uh that inspires us the way that you
felt back then as a as a young professor
younger professor um you know that's
sort of tantamount to that or equivalent
to that is there anything or are we just
in a different phase where now we're
just you know getting the eighth decimal
place of numbers as rutherford would say
yeah no no i'd say still it's very
dynamic and fun and exciting field i
i think
maybe the thing closest to that is the
you know the sum of neutrino masses
um
because we know it has to be something
we don't you don't know exactly what it
is and
it's
we can see a path there
we just have to make better and better
measurements something that is
maybe like that depending on your
theoretical prejudice you know or are
finding uh primordial b modes
you know but i think they're
um
you know i
i don't think anyone would be surprised
if they didn't exist
at measurable levels you know just at
levels above the foregrounds so
so in the past couple of months maybe
six months ago i had giant narlikar who
used to come to ucsd in this very office
where i'm at now and you've been here a
few times but this office where i'm at
now is uh former uh home of jeffrey
burbidge and jeff gerbige uh my late
great colleague was uh the close friend
and colleague of fred hoyle who was a
character in the field of cosmology
titanic theoretical astrophysicist and i
would say that uh still to this day
giant believes in the steady state or
the variance thereof um i would i would
ask you you know and and he's not an uh
ill-informed person i mean he can answer
uh he he did foundational contributions
gravity and and also in stellar
nucleosynthesis and things like that
but what would you say to somebody like
that he's not a flat earther he's not an
anti-vaxxer he's not a global warming
deny what do you say to somebody a lyman
as one of the world's foremost
preeminent experimentalists how can you
or can you not convince somebody of the
reality of the you know origin of the
universe at least in the in the fact
that it was once extremely hot dense and
it had a big bang like characteristic if
not a singularity something very very
unlike what we existed today
i said uh
probably approach it on two fronts maybe
on the really basic front we know it was
hotter in the past just from looking at
the sc signature
which is now measured with high
significance you know just the ratio
between frequencies as you go back and
redshift i think that's
that's a measurement right and if you
have a different model
you have to be able to explain that some
well the data fit the idea of a hotter
universe in the past
brilliantly
through across multiple experiments
that's that's important
you need to come up with something
special to do that in terms of
things like the spatial structure you
know there was this
i think it was um
uh
neil turock and maybe rob crittenton
were
pushing this idea that you could create
you you could make all the
patterns we see in the microwave
background from causal processes
within the horizon and that would be
fine
and then it was my colleague and friend
uh dave spurgle and i well you should
remember who
did this other work with right that
point maybe is matthias or some
pointed out
that the uh
that that wouldn't be the case
for the temperature polarization
cross-correlation at large angular
scales
because in order to make that you really
have to have super horizon fluctuations
you know because in anyone's model
opposite sides of the universe
can't have talked to each other in any
reasonable
you know amount of time so
so to get a correlation on huge angular
scales takes a very special condition
and
and so
then the chain is that you know if uh
there have to be super horizon
fluctuations
our
our cosmic horizon is you know expands
into them we see them
and
so this correlation between polarization
and temperature then of course was we
measured it with wmap so i'd say those
are two
pretty difficult observations to explain
they're both really deep right i mean
they're
they're
you really have to push something to
explain those
because um
there it's it's not in one spot in the
universe it's the whole universe is like
that in terms of clusters going back
it's not any one group of clusters it's
all clusters that do this
when you look at um you know our friends
uh you know across the alley over there
at the institute for advanced study or
elsewhere they spent a lot of time
thinking about theories of everything
string theories i've had on juan
maldosena
and others um and and you know there's
kind of this quest for an underlying
description that will unify all the laws
of nature in one law that as my guest
this past month uh michio kaku said it
will be the god equation an equation
that will fit in one inch long uh font
uh and that will uh represent all the
laws of name is there an analog an
experiment is there like a decisive
experiment is there an experiment that
would garner the headlines and sort of
the attention of the world the way that
our theorists colleagues enjoy uh
attention or is experiment of a
different character how do you view
experiments in this way of of
they're essential to
validating theories
but we don't seem to get as much
attention and i'm not complaining i get
plenty of attention
maybe too much
my colleagues would argue
but why is it that that experiment
doesn't get more attention or maybe
maybe that's an okay thing from your
perspective
well i don't know maybe we're just
not as good talking about it you know i
think there are um
so are there analogs i don't know
actually i'm not sure is there a theory
of everything i mean i'm sure there are
advances you know i mean i i can fully
believe my theoretical colleagues will
figure out a way to tie in gravity and
and
the you know the standard model of
particle physics
at some point they take a while but
they'll get theirs and is that itself a
theory of everything i'm not so sure it
seems it seems always seems to be
another layer
analog in uh
for experiment
you know
i you know i think maybe this is just an
experimentalist point of view when we
look we find things we don't expect
always
there's always something a little new
some
little toe hold
that can then take you in a whole new
direction
and
and it's uh
you know it's a it's a long process of
chipping away and making really sure you
understand your measurements
and
and then slowly you know
putting the picture together
getting rid of the chaff
and realizing no this this is really a
new aspect of nature
you know and then theorists compile on
but you know there's that element that's
always that's always going on and and
you can and you know
the rate at which you forget theories
that weren't quite right is huge right
and and you can even see this in the you
know just
in the more standard things you can say
in the microwave background right
although the foundations were laid out a
long time ago
um
you know there were tons and tons and
tons of other theories that just
increasingly didn't fit the data didn't
fit the data didn't fit the data
and
if the universe had been different we
would have
been forgetting about all the theories
we
that we take for granted now
and
you know when i think in that
astro this happens all the time right i
mean yeah a quasar right i mean what i
mean i mean where did this come from in
particle physics it would happen you
know i mean these
uh neutrinos weren't dreamed up out of
nothing
right now i mean what happened you know
i mean that you know neutrinos had mass
was a possibility that they had that
they that the mass eigen states were at
the flavor eigen states i mean who
this these are discoveries on how nature
is and so i
it's dynamic the time scales are just
much different and um
so i'd say there's
in that sense it's just uh it's
we're measuring things better so there
isn't a i don't think there is
an analog and
i i don't think uh
you have to be
maybe a little myopic maybe if you're in
your field there's a magic measurement
but i think in general no they're just
there's too
much nature out there to understand
better and more deeply so
so
speaking of eminent theoreticians and
experiment
um quote by paul dirac
and he said
i think there is a moral to the story
namely that it is more important to have
beauty in one's equations than to have
them fit experiment
it seems it seems that if one is working
from the point of view of getting beauty
in one's equations and if one really has
sound insight one is on a sure line of
progress how do you react to that that
it's more important that sort of the the
theory be beautiful because a lot of my
colleagues in theory that aren't string
theorists a sale string theory as being
lost in math as one book recently put it
or not even wrong as another book put it
what do you make of this that that some
theorists say that by virtue of the
beauty the elegance of it and as your
colleague well maybe uh i don't never
fully understood how the institute
relates to to prince but as natty
seiberg once said um we string theorists
are very arrogant if we find something
beyond string theory we shall call it
string theory
so it seems to me that they focus on
this as almost unfalsifiable but a lot
of them are based upon the notion that
it's too beautiful to be wrong what do
you say about that is experiment not the
ultimate arbiter of reality
yeah no i mean i maybe take a longer
view i
i
i don't know if it's wrong if it was
that and that that point of view just
doesn't connect with me you're what
connects with me is
as an observer of theorists of course
not a theorist you know if it's
if it is beautiful and it hangs together
there's
there's something there and it may not
you know it may not reveal
something measurable today
it and it may just be an element of
something that leads to something
measurable in in a hundred years right
if it's
logically consistent and connects with
reality in enough ways and other things
we know there's
probably something really neat there and
and just give it some time
let it
let it grow i mean these
these connections that pop out of these
theories are
you know they're they're wonderful to
see in retrospect as
i was just i just taught stat mac
and
this is uh
you know
this isn't quite an example of what
you're saying about but i think it's
it's it's related uh you know so gibbs
had the you know that there was the
gibbs paradox
and they're all you know
the theorists of the time we're trying
to figure out
you know they they knew that
that uh
you know that if you divided a
volume of stuff in half that the entropy
divided in half right
and
but they realized that they had to to to
make that work in the equations they had
they had to assume the the particles
were indistinguishable but they didn't
know why and they came up with all these
reasons right and then it took
i don't know 20 or 30 years later it
took quantum mechanics
right this abstract development in
another field another asp you know
another subfield of physics
to see why that was true and all of a
sudden this made sense
so i sort of view you know this is you
know and then you know that was based on
math it was developed
quite independently i think of all the
stuff that that
gibbs was working on right so i can just
see that happening but it happens on a
longer time scale right so it's all it's
all good and works together and i can
see the excitement and i
this idea of
not even wrong just does it just doesn't
even compute for me
well sticking with beauty and experiment
and now getting rid of the theory
component um what is the most beautiful
experiment uh that you've ever been
involved with or that you're ever
encountered maybe nothing
to do with you but just an experiment
that you feel is particularly beautiful
or elegant uh or moving to you almost on
a visceral level
well there's so obvious one for the
stuff i'll leave aside stuff i've worked
on yeah okay fine
let me you know i'll praise that
separately
ligo is a beautiful experiment
just
um
purely from an experimental point of
view
and
just the
understanding of the
noise limits the pushing of
technology
um
and of course what it was after
so that's a
that that was beautiful the rather you
know and i i don't think uh
you know beautiful experiments don't
have to always
make brilliant discoveries like
like ligo but you know i think uh
dickey's principle of equivalence
experiment was was another beautiful
experiment
really pushing technique
um
yeah
i really like the you know what the ed
flash gun is keeping in that line what
the espos group has done
i
yeah i could come up with a long list
you know some of these atomic physics
experiments just blow my mind
i mean these this precise control these
um amazing clocks and now these arrays
of atom
manipulating atoms
really you know
manipulating arrays of atoms and looking
at their interactions
and excitations
i just they're
to me they're all they're all beautiful
and and
just things that weren't
well at you know
maybe gravity and equivalence were in
the cards when i was a student but not
these other ones they've just
taken our concept of
nature in our interaction with nature
just to whole new
levels you mentioned uh dickie i wanted
to uh to bring him up uh because he's
kind of a unique figure in that he made
foundational contributions to
to our understanding and quantum
mechanics and gravity and general
relativity but also in experimental
physics um did you ever interact with
him uh
if so what was it what was he like did
you do you have any recollections of
meeting him or knowing him
oh yeah no no so he was he used to when
i
first started here at princeton he
had the
um
office two doors down from where i am
now
and uh
of course i met him i'd say
hi i
i
he gave me advice and i
uh
and you know i also i've worked
spent a huge amount of my career on the
microwave background
by far the
the majority of it
but i
i i've always wanted to do something
else so
uh
soon after i got here i had this idea of
of
building an experiment
to
look at the motion
of a
really low mass particle suspended in a
tiny pendulum
to see if there were differences from
gaussian fluctuations and this was
inspired by uh
i think there's a
an astrocar
paper
you get that you know an order of plank
mass particle a couple of fluctuations
in the metric and that just sounded
really cool to me
so i sort of sketched out you know how
to how to do this experiment and
i went and talked with dickie and he
said
let me let me think about this
and then he
he's called me back a couple of laters a
couple a couple days later said all
right lymon
don't here's what's wrong with it go
measure the microwave background
that sounds good to me and anyway that
was uh he saved you some time yes yeah
yeah well it's just uh and just and
offers a bunch of good insights
you know here's here's what's going on
and of course you were one of the uh
original co-investigators on the wmap
satellite uh it was eventually named
after uh my uh
grand advisor a phd advisor advisor
david wilkinson uh talk about david what
was he like as a uh i imagine you guys
are very close um and that he was uh he
cast a a long shadow on on the career
that that you've gone on to have so so
distinguished of a career what was he
like as a as a mentor as kind of a you
know a vulcular figure to you and to
others in the cmb community
of course he was the
the big daddy in the community i think
he trained many of the people
with partridge they built the first you
know experiment to
dedicated to going after the anisotropy
um
he uh
what were
notable aspects you know if you went and
looked at our
list of
astrophysical journals
right he
would uh and this is back of course back
in the day when everyone just had a wall
full of astrophysical journals right
he'd just write on each on the spine of
each you know the articles that he was
most interested in and they were really
broad
he liked
looking at new techniques different ways
of measuring things
going after different physics you know
looking
looking for the first stars you know i
think
uh as
you know
the history of ccds had an element
starting with dave except he didn't look
at objects with them right he got some
of the first ccds
to not
image galaxies but to image dark spots
in the sky
to look for extra galactic background
light
you know he's he was working uh when i
first got here on a new measurement
technique using rydberg atoms looking at
excitations with rydberg atoms to try to
make a more sensitive
uh microwave background receiver
and so he's always doing some of these
things and you know and then even in
in his last decade he was working on a
seti project he spent quite a bit of
time on it
and this was uh
this is this is a project
that um uh
horowitz at uh harvard started and they
were looking this was optical seti so he
took princeton's telescope and he and
norm jurassic and and uh
ed growth
they made a really uh
you know fast time constant optical
receiver and they synced it up with one
up at harvard and they were looking at
coincidences
just on the idea that if there were
extraterrestrial life right they
wouldn't waste their time with radio
signals they'd be beaming laser beams at
us and they'd be encoding it in fast and
fast transitions so you know he was he
was really broad and and uh in what he
liked and his focused on measurement
um
also always
reassessing
and and uh
i i find i'd do that more and more i
don't know if i got it from him i'm sure
i got some of it from him or whether i
was just always
like that
but you know yeah i can tell you even in
the in uh
you know as we're
trying to finish the design of wmap you
know
dave would
maybe we should turn this channel and
make it just a polarimeter
it's like no day we've got to do this
anyway it's just you know just ideas
about how to measure things and what's
interesting and always pushing and i
think
always reassessing um
what you're doing so
anyway and
just a
just a fun person yeah
lots of time together and
and i ain't really talking about
i only met him a couple times he used to
play tennis with one of my father's uh
late father's uh friends i coaching in
the math department sure
um and uh yeah he's just as i say a
vuncular figure and you know i think
that you have some of that dna in in
terms of mentorship and and i've always
you know been curious do you have a
do you ever study leadership do you
study you know kind of mentorship or is
it something that you know kind of
pretty naturally comes
to you you know as your as your boyish
good looks come to you
do you have a you're kind of like
perpetually you know like a 32 year old
uh do you did you ever study you know
like business or you know
did you ever work at becoming a mentor
do you think it's just something a gift
that people have or don't have
oh man i
i
i that's
so
i've never really studied it i've asked
lots of questions about it just you know
from and i've heard lots about it from
being on
advisory boards
and from
uh just you know
certainly in for wmap just seeing how
nasa work
was a real eye-opener i mean i i was
just
i was in tune with just how that
structure worked and how man and how
their project management worked and how
it didn't work and what you had to guard
against and things like that so it's
just a matter of just absorbing it by
osmosis
you know and friends in business and
you know
hear about fan out and
what you have to guard against and
and then as
you know
chair it's like being thrown in the deep
end right and you sit
sink or swim
in your mind
uh so i don't know so so i haven't
studied it but certainly i'm really i am
aware of it how these structures work
it's just
something to pay attention to
so in your national academy page uh it's
it's it's fairly scant but it has uh it
has some some interesting information a
piece of it is uh is about one of your
hobbies which is which is sailing
and uh
and again you uh you mentioned that you
know sailing in this is is important to
you and also that you spent a year in
antarctica um are those connected in any
way as you know you know not a lot of
great things happened to the original
sailors that went to antarctica were you
uh concerned at all when you went to
antarctica uh from a nautical point of
view or did you think everything would
work out just just fine no no so i
didn't sail there right i know you
didn't know sorry
no no so when i went
that would be i i dreamed about it but
yeah no no next question
no i i just um
oh i can just i can tell you how that
happened and you'll you can
maybe i shouldn't uh but i will oh no
please
i was in college yeah bowdoin at bowdoin
and
i applied to graduate schools
half-heartedly
i think i wasn't you know i wasn't
i got into some places but it just i
just wasn't my head wasn't there
um
my girlfriend broke up with me
i saw this ad for research in the
antarctic
that's what i'm gonna do so i did
and i
said that's a good break i just didn't
know what i wanted to do and that seemed
like a good thing it's exciting you know
being in the antarctic it was something
new something different so i applied and
i
i
got in
and i went down there and
took care of a cosmic ray station
and uh in it first to mcmurdo
and then
went to the
uh south pole
martin pomerantz was the head of the the
program went to the south pole
uh came back to mcmurdo went to the
south pole again
both times with him second time was with
uh
we put in a solar telescope
and then mcmurdo and then
out
and then i thought i would
go to graduate school then
and uh i spent enough time with
pomerantz that i you know i got to know
him pretty well
and i talked with him and and he sort of
questioned
with how much i want to go to graduate
school and i did but
but anyway i i ended up not applying to
graduate school and i went and i
bought an old sailboat and sailed for
the next two and a half years
then i applied to class to school
and that was that was it
now uh that leads me we're gonna go out
from antarctica now we're gonna go off
the planet now i wanna ask you a
question that sometimes i ask people
uh it's kind of a gauge of your risk
tolerance but but if i sent you
uh if i if i said you can be one of the
first people to go to mars
um what would be the you know would you
ask me any questions or would you just
say you know sign me up any questions
you would ask me if i said lyman i got a
spot for you on a schooner bound for the
red planet
uh
i i just want to check out the radiation
levels and understand them to make sure
it actually make it there and
this stage of my life make it back a few
more years i would
you know i might not worry about making
it back but
um
yeah so that's the kind of adventure you
you'd you'd be willing to go on an
adventure like that you wouldn't ask you
know what's the probability that they
that the craft will make it there it's
it's the radiation exposure on like a
cosmic ray experimentalist
that's that's great the radiation is
considerable i think that's
yeah i
looked at that i
i'd so yeah i'd be inclined i mean i
think you know if i were
i i made my wife look good but if i were
you know a time in my life where i had
to where i really had to be more
responsible when the kids were growing
up yeah i wouldn't so it's not it would
mean it's some balance of responsibility
and and uh
and yes you know and i think i
and it depends how long the trip was
right you know i think
i still want to get back and
[Music]
be with my family
but uh
yeah now i don't have so many
responsibilities that i just go for and
definitely i think if you'd asked me
after college i would have gone you
would have gone yeah and maybe if they
try to ask you to be department chair
again we can uh we can pull that out uh
you already did your tour of duty there
i've done it i wonder which is harder
you know going to mars um now i'm going
to move farther out into space and i
want to ask you about uh about other
life forms you hinted at paul horowitz
and and some work maybe that david was
interested in but um what do you think
about extraterrestrial intelligence do
you do do you think fermi's paradox is a
valid one or do you think that we are
probably alone
universe is a big place
i know i don't know what you mean by
intelligence are there
is there
sentient life like us
um
it wouldn't surprise me
i mean i'm
i
you know i'm an experimentalist
i think i think
looking is important yeah
i just think that if you did
i can't imagine there's not life
you know in some something we call
biology i i
it's
it seems
hard to suppress
and they're just too many opportunities
and
and that we should be looking for it
in in terms of at our stage or beyond it
it just wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me
it's not something that uh
whatever keeps
keeps me up at night or anything like
that right i just uh
i
i would just
i would bet on it but not
you know
not be worried if we didn't find it
i i think uh in terms of all these you
know whatever
et's visiting earth
i like uh
roseanne rosanna dana's take
why do they always end up out in the
country
why don't
you know i want
i i'm not going to leave it till they
touch down you know in harvard yard or
something like that well actually i
looked it up and of all the uh sightings
around the world the majority are in
america but the majority lineman i hate
the breakthrough are on the east coast
of america oh really oh well
we're on the east coast though uh with
northeast ish but yeah you're right
there could be some in the south but but
let's not be prejudiced here no no no no
uh so behind you i think i see a bunch
of theses is that right are those uh yes
yes
yeah so you must be incredibly proud
you've had so many wonderful students uh
go on to great heights um do you feel
like a student you know is something
that can be
i don't wanna say made because that
seems artificial but but can um you know
what is the right balance of of sort of
success as a scientist an experiment is
it something that can be cultivated or
do you need to be born with it is is
there sort of this nature versus nurture
argument from having mentored so many
successful students we started off the
podcast talking about amber miller who's
now the dean of all of uh science at uh
at university of southern california
just up the road from me um you know
you've had so many spectacular students
do they come in just you know there's
princeton or you know or or is it yeah
they there's something that you can do
to bring out the best in these uh young
individuals that put their trust in you
as their mentor
you know i
i really
don't know
i do i i would say that they are all
different
they they really are and i i you know
there's some
uh
level of
uh you know
helping people
letting people i'd say more is like it
find what works for them
and their path they're they they're all
great
and uh
you know i think a huge part is
for any graduate student not mine
you know when they leave you want
any student to be
independent
strong
disagreeing with you
write some of the time not also
but but you know just uh and and you
just want that
to go and and you don't want to suppress
that
and to really like science i think it's
usa i mean i still you know i
i still love what i do i'm not
jaded or about it i it's uh
so anyway those are the aspects i
wouldn't say as a philosophy i don't
have a rubric and i just think you know
it's so it's trying to it's working with
people to see
just just
you know do science to advance
yeah
and it's uh fun to see and gratifying to
see in your book not only some of the
guests that i've had on my show like
paul steinhardt
and acknowledgments to him and to david
spurgle and dick bond who's been on the
show but also
also to students and and postdocs uh
casey wagner kevin crowley et cetera et
cetera uh many other people that helped
out with this book let's talk about the
book right now
uh which is um
which is an incredible uh i think
feat because it's you know the the old
line i think it was by um blaise pascal
who said um i'm sorry i wrote so much um
i would have uh written less if i had
less uh less time
and so it's very challenging to write a
brief history of the universe you know a
brief history of the universe by uh
stephen hawking is like 300 pages long
um what motivated you to write this book
uh besides the vast sums of money that
princeton i'm sure you dropped on your
desk that's right get you out of
retirement
thank you for sending me the signed copy
by the way i do i do
no no well thank you for your i'm
thank you very much for your kind words
the um
yeah i wrote so i
that was
very honored i won a prize
uh
many years ago the mark aronson award
and i had to
as part of accepting that they asked me
to give a public lecture
and i was i was really i was deeply
honored it was early in my career and so
i really spent a long time trying to
put together a story
for how it all worked
and it got a reasonably good reception
and i just kept improving it and
improving it and at some point i thought
i really should write this up then
you know first it was just a long
monograph and i called it a monograph
for
years and then i just kept working on it
and
working on the summer summer vacations
mostly
and then finally
got the courage to
go to the princeton university press and
say would you i asked would you publish
this i shopped around a couple of
you know earlier version and got and
there people were receptive and got some
good advice and yeah and
anyway i took it to them and they said
sure and
they wanted to be a little longer but i
pushed back
[Laughter]
in short was i thought important for
something for a topic so
dense
and so yes
it's
yeah at least for me it's one of those
things if you if you
if you
read
ten thousand words it doesn't mean
you're going to get it
better than if you read a thousand words
yeah no that's true and there's even
studies about that you know you read one
you retain one percent of what you read
anyway and you know i love when
politicians talk about you know so many
millions and billions of dollars and i'm
like do you realize they differ by three
orders of magnitude like you know if you
are if you retain a you know one percent
of a thousand page book it's pretty good
as a 10 000 page book but um the book is
divided into into many sections it has
wonderful illustrations it's it's it's
very well written as well i'm and i i
really i found it so readable i can
imagine you know a lay pro i'm a
practicing cosmologist so i could read
it extremely quickly but even a lay
audience can read it in an afternoon i
mean it really doesn't require you know
the dedication of of a textbook um i
want to run some crazy ideas by you um
and uh you know add to some of the
craziness we've already talked about one
of the theories you know aliens that's
uh one of the endorsers on the back of
the book avi loeb another by our friend
mark devlin who's a co-spokesperson
along with suzanne stags and adrian lee
of the simon's observatory he's at u pen
is one of your former post-docs um i
want to ask uh what is the universe
expanding into i have an idea but i
wanna i wanna first ask you this
question that i get asked all the time
lyman what is the universe expanding
into
what
for me i would
say i view it yeah
is
i mean it's a it's a
well first you have to define just what
you mean by the universe if this is if
it's the observable universe
it's just our
horizon is growing
if you want to if you want some bigger
version it's so
we don't know
and
we can't measure it
and it is so it's it's beyond
what we can what we can have access to
and you know one of the i think one of
the
themes of
of
modern cosmology
is that it
it's it's really prescribed by
what we can measure
right and there's a real separation
between what we can know
through measurement and not just you
know
multiple serious measurements cross
checks um consistencies between various
aspects of things
and what's and what's speculation
and
i just uh
you know i i love the thought that yeah
well well well beyond our horizon
somehow
you know
different symmetries and physics take
over
or
the universe is just completely
different
and those are fun to think about and
maybe thinking about them helps inform
what we are now
but i think in terms of uh
being able to explain what we see we
don't that's so far not necessary
so in terms so then and what it's just
expanding into
uh i'd say our our
visible our
our horizon just just spent expanding
into
more of what looks just like us right
and and you and there's no measurement
you can make
that separates that from other
possibilities
even though there are measurements we
could im that we have made that could
distinguish them right
we can tell if the universe has a
different topology
to some
level that's right we can tell if it's
asymmetric
to some level right these are all things
we can tell by measurement and
far as we know and when
it
they don't hold we could tell if
with some bounds of course
if it were finite
and
it just doesn't look that way so
anyway that's the way i think about so
not a direct answer to your question but
i think it's uh maybe a really uh
different take on your yeah i i want to
say you know i never had the chance to
be your student but i i i envy your
students for getting to have you as a
professor but i would say and i want to
get your take on this so what i think
about this i think about what is the
universe expanding into well if you go
into you know the
outside of the atmosphere and you're
going on your way to mars on your space
schooner with your wife and and so forth
and then you go outside the space
capsule and you have a little you know
aluminum cube and it's empty and you
open up that cube and it's got about a
cubic meters worth of volume and you
enclose whatever's in there you just you
just enclose it with and you seal up the
aluminum cube and you ask well what's in
there well there's about what 400 cmb
photons per every cubic centimeter or so
alignment and then there might be a
proton in there and that whole cubic
meter
and the rest there might be some dark
matter in there but everything else
between the dark matter and between the
uh the photons and the and the protons
and the neutrons and the croutons
is nothing and that's what we're
expanding into it's it it's it's that is
the nature of what the vacuum of all of
space-time is at least in my notion so
would you fail me for such an answer on
a cosmology exam well you forgot about
the neutrinos but of course
they're not going to stay in your box
they don't play nicely oh number density
brian you're not doing well
that's true i added the croutons i'm
hungry
you know it's uh
that's right that's right and that
actually brings me to something i wanted
to ask you and and you talk a lot about
the kind of remaining mysteries and the
book really reminds me a lot of gamov's
book you know uh his writing was
you know he was a expert master
communicator and one two three infinity
and other books that he had on cosmo um
if you could get an answer if you could
get a single answer and then your you
know some oracle is going to tell you
the answer to any one of the questions
that are outstanding that you leave in
this book it's kind of the cliffhanger
no spoilers are going to be proffered
but but what what answer would you most
like to know about our universe or even
outside of physics maybe what and you
know besides you know what what what
stock or what lottery number should you
play and whatever but but tell me what
what about science or or cosmology
specifically what most
would you be fascinated to learn about
if you could magically learn this
without any
without any effort other than asking the
question
it wouldn't
be about anything in the book
but even just going to cosmology
i i am just
i'm fascinated by
this link between
you know in information
and
black holes
and and the
horizon
and
you know in like in
and just how that all works
and
it just
you know i know that it just anyway i
would
so i don't even know how to formulate
the question right
but it would be just a deeper insight to
that
that connection and
um
you know i thought uh
you know beckenstein is one of my
heroes i am and then when i and when i
teach my statmet class i
do a little section on that just in the
in relation between
entropies and and
black holes and
and of course hawking for
what came next but
yeah that
you know and i i know my colleagues at
the institute have way deeper thoughts
about this i just love to be able to
understand them better but it just seems
like there's some huge link there that
that
we're missing
and uh just love to understand better
you know there's just this
just a link between information you know
and it
to be
you know
it's obviously out there right there's
the whole it went from it from bit from
wheeler which as a student i just
thought was
you know absolutely nuts
to
to now sometimes consuming me and now
you know this whole one of the simon's
projects it from cubit right anyway i i
think
so
progress along those lines i think would
i'd love to
be able to sink into and really think
about and appreciate more
fascinating
okay lyman well we have reached the end
of the regularly scheduled portion of
this podcast interview and now we're
going to do
what i call the thrilling three where i
ask
uh scripted questions of my of my uh of
my guest and i'm so honored to have
lyman page
of princeton university who's been a
mentor towering figure
in cosmology uh recipient of numerous
awards all deservedly so uh and really
just uh you know one of the greatest
benefits to being involved with the
simon's observatory is getting to work
with you lyman and uh we never really
had a chance to collaborate otherwise so
i thank jim simons for spending a little
bit of money so that you and i work
together i'm sure that's him
in maryland thank you so now we're going
to go kind of philosophical here and
they all involve either the deep future
of you specifically of humanity
generally and then your past advice to
your former self so here we go
first thing is in uh in in the future
when you uh when you are no longer with
us you will leave an ethical will
hopefully which is a summary of
teachings and maybe wisdom that you have
gleaned from your 120 or more years
hopefully on earth i ask you outside of
you know your scientific knowledge which
we'll get to maybe in a little bit but
there's anything about wisdom or or
teaching or code or ethics that you've
learned
in your life that you live by or or
would encourage others who are kind of
an ideological heir to your uh to your
knowledge is there anything that you
would
uh bequeath to people like that
um
yeah so they're more they're
something you know what you do for your
family and what you do for students or
different things let me stick for the
student side yeah
i think uh
it it's sometimes lost
that uh on
on students but
i i
deeply believe there is a
physical
external
reality and there are deep truths
about nature
that you can find
and convey
and if there are these you know aliens
maybe we'll get to meet someday or that
we won't but in our lifetimes but who
knows communicate with they will share
those same
truths
they will have to share a number of them
if they're communicating
any different
and that we can find that we can find
that truth and
through many avenues
but i think that you can is
that you can know
real things about the world that is
important to keep in mind it's not
it's not relative it's not a matter of
opinion it's not
you have a different view there are
things we can truly deeply know
very nice
okay now i'm going to go a little bit
further into the future a billion years
and this is evocative of richard feynman
who said if in some cataclysm
all scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to the next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information
in the fewest words
i won't say what he said because i don't
want that to influence your statement
right i know what i would say and it's
actually based on something you did and
but at first i want to hear what you
would so
you know i said
i would i
i'm not sure i'd give a sense i'd give
an image
and i i would give the
image of the
background anisotropy for a bunch of
reasons
well maybe not a bunch but a few
one
it's not going to change much in the
next billion years
it would you know for anyone who is
nearby us
it will be the same
and it will be a connection
if if we're obliterated it will be a
connection to what we know about
the
well of course the universe but
also all the technologies that went into
measuring it and explaining it
i was going to say the same thing except
i was going to put the angular power
spectrum that you measured yeah w map
because it actually subsumes feynman's
answer so feyman's answer was the atomic
hypothesis
and the atomic hypothesis i'll just say
it from my listeners who don't know uh
that little part all things are made of
atoms little particles that move around
in perpetual motion attracting each
other when they're a little distance
apart repelling upon being squeezed and
that one sentence you'll see there's an
enormous amount of information about the
world if just a little imagination is
applied now i want to say that the cmb
power spectrum that you measured uh one
of the most iconic images of all time in
science uh breakthrough of the
millennium in many people's estimations
uh is uh is is one that encodes and is
necessarily dependent upon the atomic
hypothesis
because what makes up the matter it's uh
it is obviously atoms and what makes up
more of that image is neutrinos and
photons and all the other things that go
into the universe and unknown things
like dark energy so encapsulate what we
know and what we don't know and i think
it's just much more rich than feynman so
take that fineman wherever you are
i know that if if you had a map you
could get the power spectrum that's true
you know
i'm not known for releasing my maps you
know about me and maps
let's not get uh okay that's that's
personal okay last question lyman and
then we're done and and you have a
richly deserved weekend ahead of you uh
now we're gonna go backwards in time we
went forwards in time 120 years a
billion years now we're gonna go
backwards in time to when you were 22 23
whatever you were back many years ago
and this harkens to arthur c clarke's
three laws the first law is that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and
actually i open the podcast you'll hear
with his actual voice saying those words
his second law was that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
uh i like to drop that and my faculty
colleagues every now and then and then
the third law is the only way of
determining the limits of what's
possible is to venture beyond those
limits into the impossible and that's
the name of this podcast into the
impossible ask you
for advice to your former self
what thing did you think was impossible
at age 20 or 30 but um you would advise
yourself on how to do it now that you've
had the courage to go into the
impossible
what thing that i think was
impossible
you know
maybe that i'd be president or something
you know
no i think in terms of uh
i mean i like
i would
that what's what's the way it is i mean
i think
it's almost again like i don't
think like that i think i've always
tried to do things that were well beyond
what i can imagine doing
and usually not knowing it at the time
and knowing it in retrospect
but uh
you know dreaming big taking risks
you
um
um so
you know i
completely agree with him that
you know that uh
you know discovering the limits of
of uh
what's possible mean means going beyond
and
i don't know is it
maybe it should just
i mean i can't imagine just not pushing
not trying and not trying to go beyond
and not questioning
and not
um
and and maybe just as important as
being excited about exploring no matter
what it is
awesome and so
you know whether your mind or nature or
just trying to understand better that's
what's going on
wonderful well lyman paige i want to
thank you for being not only a mentor
and a friend but a teacher to many
thousands of people around the world a
true explorer of the world and of the
universe and uh and really just just an
all-around incredible soul i want to
wish you a happy uh
and best of luck with this wonderful
book your second book after finding the
big bang which is behind you on your
shelf and i have a copy that you signed
oh yeah yeah yeah a couple years ago
written with uh bruce partridge and uh
and your colleague jim peoples lyman
have a wonderful day i'm gonna run to my
group meeting i'm gonna try to channel
some of your infectious good cheer and
leadership lyman have a wonderful
weekend thank you so much for joining us
on the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you